well first tonight does a woman have the
right to choose what she does with her
body the answer might seem obvious to
many of you but tonight in america
there's a dire direct and dramatic
threat to that right
an incredible or frankly scandalously
given draft ruling suggests the supreme
court will overturn his 1973 decision
that legalized abortion nationwide that
judgment was of course roe versus wade
now abortion splits america often
savagely along partisan lines president
biden is unequivocal in his defense of
rome he said a woman's right to choose
was fundamental and roe has been the law
of the land for almost 50 years and
would not be overturned
well i'm joined now my conservative
radio host ben ferguson the socialist
author grace blakey welcome to both of
you ben ferguson i gotta say here in the
uk
this has been me met with complete
horror uh but i'm very aware i've spent
a lot of time working living in america
that the country is very divided about
this issue of abortion and for everyone
who is screaming this is appalling today
there are many uh republicans in middle
america who will be cheering from the
rooftops what's your view
uh look number one i think this is a
victory for protecting life for the
unborn we talk about protecting children
all the time you just had a story about
a child that went missing and how
horrific it is that child has been
missing yet we have 80 plus million
children that are aborted every year so
for me this is about protecting the
rights of the unborn i think this is a
good thing second of all no one should
be horrified in the uk or anywhere in
the world that this ruling came down
because abortion if they're terrified
that it's illegal that's not accurate
this is sending it back to the states
and the states have a right to decide
what their laws are the same way that
states in america have the right on gun
laws and look democrats have put
themselves in a toughest position right
now one because they can't even define
what a woman is anymore so you can't say
it's a woman's right to choose anymore
and two they the whole my body my choice
well they've also thrown that out the
window because they want to mandate
vaccines in america so the idea now is
well let's leak it from the supreme
court let's have chaos at the court
let's try to shame people into doing
what we demand they do because we can't
define a woman and we can't say anymore
my body my choice when we demanded
vaccines okay they're in a bad spot as
they should be all right let me bring in
grace are you currently identifying as a
woman before we start yes i am okay good
well as a identifiable woman uh what's
your response to ben ferguson my
response to this is that america does
not want this the polls are clear this
is an assault on american democracy by a
highly organized group of religious
extremists who are seeking to force
women to have births and who want to
basically control use the power of the
american state to control women's bodies
this is a complete and utter violation
of basic human rights rights that the
american constitution that you hold so
dear was created to defend and that's
not even mentioning the separation
between church and state that this
clearly goes against because this is all
about this tightly organized sect
basically within america that wants to
criminalize homosexuality control
women's bodies and basically take your
country
to the 18th 19th century all right ben
ferguson you're from the 18th century
for the remain
yeah for the remainder of this interview
appears i identify as a woman because
apparently now you can do that so as a
woman now i want to make it clear she
has no idea what she's talking about
about the american laws the laws state
and she's completely wrong that you
don't rule at the supreme court based on
public opinion
you you rule on law
let me finish you never
rule on the constitution based on public
opinion
let me ask you let me ask you this
question you and i have debated for
example gun rights many times over the
years you've always made it clear to me
there's no point bringing in new gun
laws because people will still be able
to get guns i would put it to you what's
the difference ideologically if you try
and stop people having abortions legally
they'll go and find them it'll just be
more difficult and actually the people
that will suffer most will be those who
can't afford to go to other states where
it's legal so you have a country which
will be split but the people suffering
most in terms of choice will be those
who can least afford to take other
options
again you're going back to the the
problem here which is it's a public
opinion is now what you're demanding the
supreme court decide on instead of what
the law actually says you look at guns
every single state has different gun
laws and no one is freaking out over
that if you're in california
you have extreme finish let me finish
extreme gun laws the reality is
democrats have gotten themselves in a
corner because they refuse to admit what
a woman is they refuse to admit that
again that you do have rights or don't
have rights of your own body they
screwed this up and so what the supreme
court is doing and what states like
mississippi when they challenged us
of course they did you can't even define
women
this has been a concerted campaign that
existed
for religious extremism of the kind that
if it was taking place anywhere else in
the world would be rightly attacked by
the allegedly civilized liberal
democracies
okay
for the remainder of this interview i
identify as as atheists okay so
therefore we fix that problem
doesn't care about any religion wait let
me finish as somebody that has no
religion right now i've just identified
as that this has nothing to do with
religion and again if you looked at
american laws which you clearly know
nothing about the supreme court is not
making a decision on religion this is
your religious bigotry towards people of
religion and bigotry doesn't believe in
god
just in the same way that many muslims
what is your personal opinion of
abortion
uh personally i believe that abortion is
wrong i believe that you protect the
life of the unborn child at the time of
conception as a father of three i
believe that as soon as they were
consumed that is a child and that child
should be protected and not aborted do
you have a do you have i don't know i
don't know your family but do you have a
daughter
i have three sons two that are twins
from in vitro so i know a lot about
conception and when it starts all of my
children
the question i was going to ask you had
you said that one of your kids was a
daughter i just wonder what your view
would have been about the perennial
questions identifying all of them as
daughters right now so let's go there
right
now they're all daughters let's have
them identify as daughters how would you
feel if you had a daughter who was
impregnated by a rapist for example or
through incest
would you still say that she was not
entitled to have an abortion
is a great question many of the states
that are saying that they will go with
whatever the decision is on roe v wade
have said unless it's life of the mother
rape or incest they will allow abortion
in those states including many of the
conservative states that you mentioned
earlier if it is personally
my child and they came to me and they
said i was raped and i am pregnant i
still believe that that is a child a
authentic human being at the time of
conception and i do believe that you can
give that child up for adoption if you
do not want to raise that child but it's
still a child and that child's life just
deserves to be defended it does not mean
by the way that i don't think you
denying people health care why are they
allowing people to go around murdering
each other this has nothing to do with
the conversation we're not denying
health care oh full now see this is when
you know you've lost the argument when
you have to bring up another argument
nothing away with it don't talk over
each other denying people contraception
basically teaching a policy of
abstinence telling people it's wrong to
have conversation it's wrong to have sex
so when that inevitably does happen they
have no choice when they're very very
young other than just to have a child
that they don't want that is going to
completely destroy the final word
i would argue ben ferguson must have had
sex because he's got three kids so let's
just put that on the table right ben
but
yeah let me let me say this very clearly
if you're having to then go into health
care and arguing about health care to
defend your position on abortion you've
lost the argument and abortion
america let me finish
let me finish
abortion is not illegal in america
with this ruling it is going to get your
way it will
again let me finish let me finish i have
a right to an opinion so do you okay you
both have your right to opinion
supreme court has made it clear that
they have said it's a states rights
issue and that's what the issue is here
you don't understand the mission until
we see federal legislation imposed when
the republicans take back control um
that basically makes it illegal
everywhere okay your country is going
the middle east
we're going to leave it
it's a states rights issue we're going
to leave it there it's a lot this is the
kind of debate that's raging all over
america by the way so it's a good debate
to have i believe in uncensored debate
and passions are going to run very high
about this ben ferguson grace blakely
thank you both very much
thanks